bueno es que de niño crecí en la era del
apolo la misión a la luna así que
siempre supe que quería dedicarme en la
ciencia primero pensaba que quería ser
un astronauta como todos demás de mi
edad en realidad no descubrí las
matemáticas hasta que estaba en séptimo
grado construya modelos de cohetes en
ese momento y mi profesor de ciencias de
séptimo grado me enseñó cómo usar la
trigonometría para calcular qué tan alto
subían los cohetes ya mí me pareció
increíble que con las matemáticas sabría
qué tan alto llegaría algo sin necesidad
de una regla o una escalera
después me gradué de la escuela y
descubrí que si juntamos matemáticas
ciencia y computadoras todo punto nos
dan gráficos por computadora y fui muy
afortunado de poder estar desde el
inicio a principios de los 80 quede
inmediatamente atrapado
después de que me gradué de la escuela
fui a la universidad de washington y
trabaje como profesor donde empecé en un
laboratorio de gráficos por computadora
estuve ahí cerca de 10 años pero la
comunidad de gráficos por computadora
era muy pequeña en ese tiempo y todos
conocen a todos así que me mantuve en
contacto con mucha gente de pixar y
bueno diez años después de que llegue a
washington fue cuando tu historia que ha
quedado terminada y pensé oh si alguna
vez quién tendrá algo diferente este es
buen momento así que hice lo impensable
deje mi vida académica y me uní a esta
pequeña iniciativa llamada pixar cuando
llegué a pisar uno de los primeros
proyectos en los que trabajé
fue el cortometraje el juego de gehry
que fue muy emocionante porque es una
oportunidad para usar un poco de la
tecnología en la que estuve trabajando
en la universidad de washington y que
realmente se aplica a la industria
cinematográfica fue muy exitoso tanto
creativa como técnicamente ganó un
premio de la academia como mejor
cortometraje del año y después gane un
premio de la academia por el trabajo
lo que hice en el juego de gehry el
trabajo técnico el trabajo técnico que
hice en el hall de gate y se mencionó en
la lección de modelado de personajes con
alonso son las matemáticas de
subdivisión
he estado haciendo varias cosas en
diferentes momentos en mis casi 20 años
en pixar en los últimos 10 años he
estado liderando el grupo de
investigación de gráficos por
computadora entonces nuestro trabajo es
dar solución a las necesidades
tecnológicas de las películas futuras
construimos un nuevo simulador de
cabello para mérida en la película de
valiente y ahora en intensamente uno de
los investigadores
kurt fleischer desarrolló una nueva
tecnología para ayudar a los animadores
a obtener actuaciones aún más fuertes de
sus personajes viendo hacia el futuro
para los próximos 5 a 10 años una de las
cosas en la que hemos trabajado muy duro
es cómo hacer que todos estos cálculos
complejos se puedan hacer en tiempo real
son al menos 24 actualizaciones por
segundo justo ahora en algunas áreas
incluyendo simulación las
actualizaciones pueden tomar minutos u
horas por cuadro
en estos días es mucho más fácil
introducirse a gráficos por computadora
que cuando yo era un niño de hecho
cuando era un niño los gráficos por
computadora no existían en estos días si
están interesados en los gráficos por
computadora hay muchas oportunidades en
línea pueden ir por ejemplo aprender
punto org
ahí descargaron paquetes de software
gratis que haga animación con
herramientas muy parecidas a las que
usamos nosotros es gratis y tiene muchos
tutoriales muy buenos
usando prender pueden darse una idea de
cómo trabajan los artistas de pixar y
después usando pixel in a box pueden
entender algunas de las matemáticas que
necesita blender
como diversión por los últimos 10 años o
algo así mis dos hijos y yo de hecho
toda la familia hemos estado
construyendo proyectos para llevar a
este gran evento que ocurre cada año en
el área de la bahía llamado maker fire
en 2010 por ejemplo construimos un robot
de 8 pies medio de alto un dragón que
lanzaba fuego porque no verdad en el
2012 por ejemplo construimos un
simulador de vuelo basado en el programa
de televisión va a registrar galáctica y
justo el año pasado hicimos un poderoso
exoesqueleto un poco inspirado en
películas como elysium y al estilo del
mañana en esas películas los
exoesqueletos son accesorios y nosotros
dijimos podríamos construir uno que en
realidad funcione así que mi hijo menor
trajo a siete de sus amigos y llevamos
algo a la feria que realmente puso
muchas sonrisas en la cara de muchas
personas